le tournage dans le village a été une
expérience incroyable où nous avons tourné l'
enfer vert est plus haut sur l'Amazone
que toute autre caractéristique a ressenti un coup de feu
avant que
nous devions prendre comme une heure de bateau
jusqu'au village c'était comme le tout dernier
village de cette promenade en bateau  où vous avez l'
impression qu'à la fin allez-
vous y arriver c'est tellement éloigné que c'était
fou
ce n'était pas comme être sur le plateau vous travaillez
essentiellement en vivant en respirant le film
tout le temps je ne savais pas à quoi
m'attendre  la jungle tous les jours maintenant je suis
enfin tu sais faire un film où je suis en
fait là-bas à l'
expérience tu connais l'atmosphère et
tout ce que c'était comme être au
paradis on nous a dit que ça allait être un
tournage difficile et c'est  pas un
endroit facile à filmer ce serait les
occasions de test vous aurez un endroit que vous allez
adorer vous le filmerez et vous reviendrez
deux jours plus tard et il a été complètement
emporté nos plages que nous avons déjà tournées sur
notre Artie  disparaître l  représente un
énorme défi pour nous, mais à la fin, cela
ressemblait à plus qu'un tournage de film,
c'était quelque chose de vraiment spécial pour
nous tous,
vous